في أيام احتضارها ، تحارب داعش
حتى النهاية المريرة ،
بلدة باروسيل السورية الصغيرة التي لم تكن ملحوظة ،
على ضفاف نهر الفرات ، حيث تم حصرها أخيرًا إلى ظل قاتل لنفسها السابقة بمزيج من الجنود الأكراد والعرب
المدعومين من قبلنا.  تم التقاط القوات الخاصة البريطانية والفرنسية
وغارات التحالف التي لا هوادة فيها
في هذا الفيديو الحصري الذي تم تصويره بواسطة
المصور المستقل
جبريل شايم ، لقد كان من الصعب
القيام بهجمات متكررة من قبل داعش
باستخدام تكتيكاتهم المعتادة في
الأفخاخ الانتحارية بسيارات مفخخة
ودروع بشرية
والآن في النهاية بعد سنوات  من
أعداء داعش الحرب لديهم
عشرات لتسوية
القوى الديمقراطية السورية ، قائد القوات الديمقراطية السورية هافال
سيمكو حارب تنظيم داعش المعروف هنا باسم داعش
في
شمال سوريا.
ساعة
هؤلاء المقاتلين القبليين العرب يستعدون
لأخذ أرض مفتوحة على أطراف
البلدة  يعطي mmander الأوامر النهائية
قبل أن يخرجوا
من بلدوزر مدرع مصمم
لتحمل تأثير العبوات الناسفة
يقود الطريق والقوات تتبع
مشاعل تضيء السماء فوق
باروس أصوات صدى المعركة في
المسافة
تكون المعركة الأخيرة في أيامها الأخيرة
بن ويدمان CNN شرق سوريا